نشاهدها
للحظه استهداف المنزل في بيت الاهل
نشاهدها ثم اعود اليك بتفصيل
وائل اذا كنت تحدثني عن هذا المنزل قبل
قليل وقلت انه يتبع لعائله المدهون وواضح
انه دمر تماما تقريبا كما شاهدنا في صوره
اخرى ايضا قبل قليل
صحيح عثمان هذه المشاهد تتكرر على مدار
الساعه هنا في قطاع غزه
يعني شاهدنا صورا من هذا النوع متكرره في
كل المنازل تقريبا التي استهدفت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عاده ما تلجا الى
استهداف المنازل بطائرات الاستطلاع اولا
سواء كان ذلك بصاروخ او صاروخين او اكثر
لتدفع منهم يقطنوا هذا المنزل الى اخلاقه
ومن ثم تاتي الطائرات الاسرائيليه
المقاتله الحربيه كما شاهدتم في الصور
بالقاء القنابل ذات الحجم الكبير يعني بعض
فرق الهندسه والعارفين بهذا الشان تحدثوا
لنا في واحد من المنازل لعائله المصري
ايضا في بلده بيت لاهيا شمال قطاع غزه
عندما كنا نقوم بعمل مقابلات من من داخل
هذا المنزل او من على حطام هذا المنزل
قالوا بان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ت
قنابل يصل وزنها الى طن من المتفجرات
تقريبا عندما تاتي لتدمير هذه المنازل
الفلسطينيه واظن ان الصوره التي نشرت على
الرغم من انني لم اشاهدها لكنها قد تكون
نفس السيناريو ونفس المشهد وبالتالي نفس
السلاح الفتاك والقنابل الشديده الانفجار
كبيره الوزن حتى تضمن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان هذه البيوت تتحول اثرا بعد
عين وتصبح ركاما بكل مقتنياتها ومحتوياتها
وما هي فيه الناس هنا بالتاكيد حدثونا
واستمعنا الى روايات كثيره لاصحاب هذه
المنازل الذين اصبحوا في عداد المشردين
قالوا بان هذا تعب العمر وشقاء كل السنوات
الماضيه
وامكانياتهم وجهدهم بالتاكيد هم يشعرون
بكثير من الالم والحسره ولكن اللافت عثمان
في هذا السياق اننا كلما تحدثنا الى ذوي
هذه المنازل وجدنا ان روحهم المعنويه ربما
اكثر ارتفاعا واكثر صلابه حتى من
معنوياتنا نحن نحن نشعر تجاههم بتعاطف
ربما في بعض الاحيان لانهم اصبحوا مشردين
ولانهم فقدوا شقاء العمر وتعب السنين ولكن
هم
يفاجئوننا بالعبارات التي تقول فد فلسطين
وفد المقاومه وفد الشعب الفلسطيني وان
يزول كل المنازل وان يبقى الشباب هذا هو
الاهم من وجهه نظرهم وهذا ربما ما يعبر عن
حس الشارع الفلسطيني مدى التفافه حول
المقاومه الفلسطينيه خصوصا عثمان بان
الشارع الفلسطيني الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى
مقتنع بان
اسرائيل هي من اعتدت بشكل واضح
واعتدت بشكل كبير جدا
واغتالت ثلاثه من اكبر قاده سرايا القدس
وهم بين احضان ذويهم واهلهم في شقق سكنيه
عمارات سكنيه مناطق سكنيه وكان الاعتداء
والعدوان واضحا بشكل كبير الامر الذي شكل
تحريضا اضافيا
للشارع الفلسطيني ارتفاع حول